if there were a way to get your business
or new product to 2x 10x or 100x
overnight would you do
it if there are a way to all but
guarantee that no matter what business
you're in it could become more
successful than it currently is would
you do
it and if you could compress a decade of
building a business into
weeks would you do
it if so this Workshop is for you and
using the super influencer process I'll
outline in a second will make someone
here today enough money to retire that
is a
promise I would know because I've also
used what I'm about to share with you to
do exactly that I'm Alex fosi my first
big business I scaled at $2.5 million a
month which was B2B gym launch was gym
licensing my second business was an
e-commerce business that sold through an
affiliate and influencer program which
got to $1.7 million a month which is B2B
to see my third company was a software
for lead gen agencies which we grew
entirely off of Affiliates and
influencers which we got to $1.6 million
per month and so I've paid real money to
get influencers to promote my businesses
just to give you some context I spent
over 20 million on influencers to
promote Prestige Labs that's the actual
checks that's what we that's what I paid
out now we made that's what I paid out
and in Allen I spent over $22.8 million
on influencers to promote the software
those are my actual payouts from our
dashboard and I've had over 23,000
Affiliates who promoted my last book
$100 million leads that's a screenshot
from our uh CRM which helped me sell
over a million copies of my last two
books $100 million offers and $100
million leads and you can see the slack
message from my book manager there and
so this process that I'm about to share
with you creates real lifechanging value
and it allowed me to sell my first two
businesses to American Pacific group for
46 .2 million and sell Allen with a
trailing 12 month of $12 million in
revenue and then use all that money to
start acquisition. comom to invest in
and scale companies and currently our
portfolio together ises about $17
million a month and so I've made
Millions using influencers to promote my
businesses and I can help you do the
same and so I start with this proof
because there's a lot of sucky fluff
that's being taught out there like this
fluff sucks from people who've never
done what they claim and simply copy and
paste stuff that they don't understand
people being like I teach things that
I've never done and I refuse to do
that and so after spending losing and
then finally making millions on
influencers I've learned a lot of what
not to do but I also figured out a few
things that work and so today I'm going
to share with you a three-step super
influencer process anyone can use to get
a flood of buyers into your business for
free even
and especially if you have no following
or money
yourself and so here is the three-step
process number one know which influencer
to pick number
two know how to get them to talk to you
and then number three I'm going to show
you how to get them to promote your
stuff because if you know who to pick
and you get them to talk to you you get
them promote your stuff you will make
more money than if you do not and
arguably if you pick the right
influencer you might make life-changing
amounts of
money and so think about it this way if
tomorrow the rock or Taylor Swift agreed
to promote your business do you think
your business would grow no matter what
you sell be it umbrellas Contracting
tequila or VA agencies or whatever it is
if the rock got up there and said this
is the dude do you think you would make
more money
obviously of course it would and better
yet do you think there's any single move
and this is the key point we talk about
opportunity cost of the time and effort
we put into every move we make in
business do you think there's any single
move that you could make that would make
you more money in less time than
partnering with someone like
that no probably not so then why on
Earth are we not putting all of our time
into the one thing that could make you
the absolute most amount of money in the
shortest period of time I don't know why
not and so before I dive in let me
explain why taking action what I'm about
to share with you with you may be the
most important decision in your life all
right so obviously option one you could
be lame option two do it and change your
life so I'm going to opt for option two
and hopefully you do too and so there's
a reason that this is so important
especially right now there's a big shift
that's happening in the economy and
specifically the economy of
attention traditional advertising is
dying social media and influencer brands
are on the rise you've all heard this
but let me show you some stats to
support it all right it's the reason
that Logan Paul and prime a 2-year-old
Company 2 years old is now beating they
have more sales than power raid a 36y
old company two years 36 and they're
crushing them it's the same reason Mr
Beast febles a less than 2-year-old
company are in the multiple hundreds of
millions of dollars a year in sales and
they're gaining rapidly on Hershey's
which was something that before this
time and age was thought to be
impossible and it's why so many mega
brands are getting launched with
influencers like Kylie has her Cosmetics
proper 12 with Conor McGregor Kim has
skims and you've got Ryan Reynolds with
Aviation Jin and he's got a bunch of
other brands as well so many of these
Mega brands are getting launched with
mega influencers or super
influencers because they can almost
guarantee profitability on day
one so think about it like this if you
can reach 1 million people for free as
long as your product sells for more than
it costs you make money
period and so the question just becomes
which thing will make the most money
rather than whether that thing will make
money at all so Mr Beast here has to
make the decision of am I going to
promote Margaritas or am I going to
promote chocolate but if he did promote
Margaritas guess what he would still
make money not as much as he could if he
did chocolate but he would still make
money and what crazy world can you live
in that you can guarantee millions and
millions in sales on something that
actually has poor product Market fit
this is one of those big insurance
policies you can take out on the future
of your business if you make the right
pick and this has never existed before
this moment until now and so here's some
graphs because everybody likes graphs
it's the same reason they're more
viewers on internet than they are on
television more listeners and they're
all radio listeners and even crazier
this costs less and converts higher
which means that there's more total
people watching listening and consuming
and more of them buying for less money
overall the game has changed yet so few
businesses are taking advantage of it
and so you can see why this is such a
huge
opportunity said differently if the only
thing between you and the fastest
business growth you could possibly
imagine was three
steps wouldn't be worth
doing great I think so too so let's dive
in the three-step super influencer
process how to pick them how to get them
to talk to you how to get promote your
stuff so let's start with number one how
to pick the right influencer so there
was a movie that came out a year ago or
a year or two ago called air and the
premise was simple Nike a shoe brand was
struggling to enter the basketball
Market at the time
this is not drawn to scale the
representation is that they weren't
making that much money everybody else
was making more fantastic and every year
they would spend money on player
sponsorships and they would get quote
second tier rookies to wear their stuff
there's the guy he's second tier he's
wearing Nike and they kept losing the
best players every year to Adidas and
Converse yes Converse was actually a big
player back then and so the exhausted
partnership manager AKA talent scout
insisted to Phil Knight that they go all
in on this new Young rookie
named Michael
Jordan he was one of the top picks and
they bet their entire basketball budget
so they took what they were going to pay
five to 10 players and just gave it to
one and they did it in order to sign
him and he got the biggest deal that
anyone had ever signed because Nike
needed him more than he needed them and
they hoped they hoped that they would do
$2 million in basketball shoe
sales but instead they did 122 million
in the first year and they created an
iconic brand that has yet to be
surpassed decades later and you can see
how Nike now eats the entire
pie all because they went all in on the
right influencer they picked the right
guy and so the question for you is who's
your Michael Jordan and so there's two
ways you can approach this one you have
a branded product and you go find a
super influencer to partner with so you
have the thing and then you go to find
the person or two you find the person
and then you brand something around them
either
works so the Nike Air story was an
example of number one Nike was selling
basketball shoes people who wear
basketball shoes tend to watch and
idolize basketball players so finding
the best available basketball player
made the most sense for them in this
case Michael Jordan so they kept their
brand and then Jordan promoted a
personal line that's how they married
the two cuz he needed them less than
they needed him but Nike overall was
still a bigger brand than Michael Jordan
was especially as a
rookie an example of number two is some
company that you probably haven't heard
of which is Congo Congo is a drink
manufacturer they have three massive
Brands underneath of their umbrella and
one of them is prime the other two also
do half a billion dollar a year in sales
and you've heard of those too but for
the purpose of the presentation I'm just
going to focus on Congo so Congo you've
never heard of Logan Paul you probably
have and so they decided to say we're
going to go find the influencer and
create the product that's branded for
them and we're going to do the
delivery and so the difference these two
examples is Nike you get the pro the
influencer to promote your
brand or you deliver on theirs that's
the difference between the two models
both
work and so which brand you use depends
on who has the bigger audience cuz
you're like wait how do I get which one
well it just depends who's bigger so
Nike had a bigger audience than Jordan
so he promoted them now he was still up
he was bigger in basketball than Nike
and so they created a specific line
around Jordan so that's kind of the
Nuance of this and that's why
understanding how this works is so
important for you actually executing on
it Logan Paul has a bigger audience than
Congo more people have heard of him than
Congo and so they delivered for him and
so you can get an army of tiny
influencers or find one super influence
and the pro tip here is that the first
if you want to find lots of little guys
who are 100K each right it will take you
longer but you'll be able to retain more
ownership because you'll pretty much
always be bigger than
them and that's what I did in these
companies so with Prestige labs and
Allen both of those I had lots of lots
of little Affiliates lots of little
influencers the second is faster and
easier to manage but you give up more
now I will say personally that I lean
far more towards this now as I
understand branding and I understand
speed to Market and I understand the
value of aggressive growth and the
insurance policy that a super influencer
provides to a
business which is exactly what we did
with school I both co-own and act as my
own influencer for the school games and
school the platform
itself and so you might be like okay
well that's great for Nike and Prime and
febles and
school but what about me what about
everyday business owners how do we
actually get in contact with influencers
and super
influencers well first you have to know
who buys the sort of stuff you sell the
fancy term for this is ideal customer or
Avatar or
ICP then you got to figure out the
influencers they
follow then you got to pick out the
super influencers from there that best
fit your
product and so I think about contacting
people in layers so this is tactical all
right so everyone take notes like this
is the part where you take notes on it
all right so first I start with
influencers I know personally now you
might be like well I don't know
influencer believe it or not you
probably do know someone personally they
might not be Logan Paul but they
probably have a bigger following than
you I can almost guarantee that you know
someone who has a bigger following than
you that's why you know
them and if you contact all of them or
don't know any because I'm going to give
all the people with excuses in the room
they're like I don't want to talk to
people I know okay fine so if you did
contact all of them or you don't know
any then you move on to the next Circle
which is I ask my network who they know
I say okay I don't know any big
influencers do y'all know any big
influencers and when I make this point I
want to emphasize this actually ask you
can even cut the person that you ask in
on your side of the deal if they make an
intro and it actually works out and you
can pay real money for this because it's
exceptionally valuable for you and your
business for all the points I already
made and so you just say something like
do you know XXX person or do you know
anyone who has that size audience or who
caters to this type of people
and if you want to add the optional I'm
paying XXX for an
intro now if they don't know anyone so
this is for the people who have excuses
in the room if they don't know anyone so
you don't know anybody and your friends
don't know anybody because you live in a
rock fantastic then you move on to the
next circle out which is influencers you
follow or have heard of and what I do is
I reach out everywhere multiple times
and find Mutual connections and I harass
the living hell out of them and offer
bounties and crazy gifts and when I say
harassing living hell I mean of my
friends not the person all right to be
very clear great way to not get a
partnership done but reaching out on
multiple channels super smart so if you
follow them on Instagram also look at
them on LinkedIn look at them on Tik Tok
look at them via email look at Via
Direct Mail people forget about this you
can actually deliver stuff to people's
address by the way you can't unsubscribe
from Direct Mail fun fact all right so
there are things that you can do to get
people's attention and here's what's
interesting somebody who has a very
large following on Instagram might have
a very small following on L LinkedIn and
they might check both of their inboxes
but where do you think you're more
likely to stand out when they get one of
10 inbox messages on LinkedIn versus the
one of 1,000 they get on Instagram right
go everywhere because you might stick
out and you can follow up to be clear
I'm not saying don't follow up do that
but I definitely want to take the people
I know and ask them for
it and now if none of them respond to
you then you can go through formal
channels and this is a little bit of a
pro tip so one obviously some of these
guys will have agents if you if you're
looking for super influencers and I will
say this having now dealt with super
influencers it's not as much as you
think most of the time most of the time
it's not nearly as much as you think if
you're a bigger business owner for those
of you who get that otherwise you'd be
like I have to spend $10 million to get
this person honestly Superstars you can
get for a couple hundred grand a year
you'd be
amazed now here's the little Pro tip for
you
most influencers of some sort have a
website and most of them sell at least
one thing and a little Pro tip for you
is just actually go to their website as
another place and opt in actually
contact support actually Reach Out find
the email address on the site and reach
out you'll be amazed at again instead of
going to the Thousand DM inbox on
Instagram that there might only be six
people who are actually emailing so just
don't make the assumption that because
lots of people see it lot lots of people
take action so I'm going to tell you a
quick analogy in this because I think
this will drive it
home we recently put out uh we did a we
did a contest for editors because we
have a big media team at MOS media and
we had 1,200 people off of one post said
that they were interested in the role
now many people were probably like oh
man I don't want to apply for something
like that because I probably don't have
a shot well wait for the second stat we
then gave all of those 1,00 people who
who wanted to be editors one raw file
and we said just edit it and you've got
48 hours to send it in guess how many of
the 1,200 the 1,200 people actually
submitted an
edit
60 60 5% one in
20 so the odds are still in your favor
if you actually take action you would be
and that's a pretty big number and it's
the same thing going for jobs going for
girls going for whatever you want you'd
be amazed how low the bar is if you
actually
try and so that's how you pick them
tactically all right so let's just recap
this for number one find find this
biggest person that you connect with
using the circles if your audience is
bigger than theirs then you ask them to
promote your thing if Their audience is
bigger than yours you offer to deliver
for them finding your quote Michael
Jordan can give you the benefit of years
of building a massive audience without
the time
cost and you immediately reap the
benefits of their work in exchange for a
portion of the upside and so that's how
you pick the right influencer number one
so let's move on to step two you're like
okay I've got my eyes on this guy I've
got my eyes on my Michael Jordan now you
got to get them to talk to you so no
matter how good your thing is or the
offer that you want to make them if they
don't respond to you or you can't get a
hold to them you're not going to get
very far so here's how I get them
interested verify yourself the magic
message and the rule 100 three steps so
let's walk through the first one so
verifying yourself has two individual
steps first you literally verify
yourself on the platform if you can pay
the $10 per month or whatever it is to
get the blue check mark all right you do
this because you will get five to 10
times the response rates and so if I
think about my time as valuable if I can
get if I can compress my time to 10x
time for $10 a month I cannot imagine a
better use of resources that means for
10 bucks you can get 5 to 10x the time
back absolutely worth it step two of
verif yourself is don't be like Rakesh
000018 don't be like him be like Jim Jim
has a verification badge he has a
description of what he does by the way
if you want to partner with influencers
to do stuff say so in the description
say what you want them to see if you're
like hey I'm reaching out to influencers
and it just says like big music head and
you're reaching out about e-commerce
stuff probably not a good idea they're
going to immediately read your social
resume and be like this guy has nothing
to do with what he's offering me if you
want to be a professional act like a
professional do it for money do it like
it's your job because it
is he's a profile picture now one thing
that I would fix about Jims is I would
make it more more of his face closer up
and lighter lighter and brighter if you
will I put mine there because of course
you know magic social media man that I
am um mind you I had to learn this the
hard way my first version of this was
like I was zoomed all the way out and
you couldn't have seen it was super
pixelated all right and so I've learned
this stuff over time so you want to make
sure you have a picture that makes you
look like human being fantastic and then
actually use the platform post a few
things that show who you are on whatever
platform you choose to so you can see
he's got post obviously this guy's into
music and his stuff's about music that
makes sense by the way I don't know
either of these people I just grabb them
from my DMs I just saw who stood out and
who were people had guarantee would
never respond to all right so in short
don't be a weirdo don't look like Rakesh
be like Jim and to be fair Rakesh if you
do watch this I don't think you're
necessarily a weirdo you're displaying
like one all right so number one verify
yourself check so now if we have
verified ourselves we got to figure out
what we're actually going to say to them
so let me give you the magic message so
this is a sample message script you
would send this to an influencer hey
longtime fan firsttime messenger I own a
company that partners with influencers
to start communities this was one I made
for school that they own based on your
following it looks like you generate
anywhere from X to Y per month in
recurring income here are screenshots of
people who started this month alone mind
you the screenshots don't necessarily
need to be from you they're just
screenshots of other people who've had
the same experience you get the majority
of the profits we do a majority of the
work would you be up for a 15-minute
call for me to walk you through what
something like this would look like
that's it very
straightforward now to be clear the more
personalize the message the better you
only need one person to say yes put the
time in to actually look like you took a
moment to think about this person don't
just blast a hundred of these messages
copy and paste I say long time longtime
follower first-time messenger guess who
some of the best people to start with
are people you actually follow bonus
points if they've already interacted
with you before in the past and guess
what if they don't respond
congratulations you just got practice
for
free bonus points if it is your dream
influencer offer to fly out to show them
you're serious if you incur costs they
will take you more seriously if you want
to play with the pros you got to act
like a now if you're listening to this
you're watching this and you're like
well I don't have the money to fly out
that's fine but if you want to play in
the big leagues you got to do what you
got to do and they're not going to take
you seriously because they want somebody
who has some level of resources and
success now you can fake it before you
make it which I'm not really a fan of or
you just say I'm going all in on this
and you make the BET and you're going to
strike out sometimes and that's okay
because life is long and you only need
one and so what you'd say something like
this you'd say hey I'm out that way all
the time so it's no big deal I'm happy
to stop by so we can meet one another
and see if there's an opportunity that
makes sense the key part is like I'm out
that way all the time because they also
don't want to in inconvenience you but
if you're like oh it's no problem I'm
out there that way anyway because it
also shows that you're busy you're doing
other stuff you're they're not the only
uh only only frog in the kettle I don't
know if that's a saying I'm going with
it okay fantastic and next little bonus
tip is that if they have a public office
spend time and money on an scen gift and
a handwritten card and offer to pay a
lot of money for them not you ahead of
time for just 15 minutes and I'll be
very clear about that last point the
amount of people who are like hey I'll
pay $100 for your time that might be a
lot of money for you that might not be a
lot of money for them and so you got to
understand who you're playing with right
if you if you're going up to kmen
Electra shoot what's gen Z's equivalent
of that uh Haley Bieber now she's
married who's a hot girl Sydney
Sweeney Sydney Sweeney great you're
going to Sydney Sweeney and you're like
hey babe we got out to dinner dinner's
on me not a very compelling offer for
SNY cuz they've got guys who will
literally pay for all the food for the
rest of her life and her travel and not
just to get a picture of her underwear
anyways the point is the point is calm
down the point is is that you have to
make it relevant to the influencer or
the super influence that you're that
you're going for it has to be something
that they would actually value and the
personalization I will say on a personal
level that first one about making a big
obscene gift it's more about the thought
and the effort that someone can see that
you incurred to put the gift together so
I got an amazing gift the other day it's
a it's a full SI don't copy this it's
already been done all right so I got a
full-size uh modern art piece that had
uh the background of a of an Ace of
Spades because we're we're in Vegas our
headquarters in Vegas and it had this
cool graffiti is paint all over it of
the quotes that I had influenced the
artist on and so it was all the quotes
that he had had for me that had made an
impact on his life and I got that and I
was like this is so cool and it was
clear and obvious that he spent a lot of
time putting this together and it was
relevant to me and so as a side note
this is yet another Pro tip for you if
you're going to give a gift to somebody
and you're a business owner don't put
your logo on it put theirs on it why
would I wear someone else like it
doesn't make any sense I want you to
make something that I would want to wear
all the time and then I will think of
you every time I wear it then I create
the positive Association okay bonus
points over fantastic so you verify
yourself you look like a legitimate
person you send the magic message you
offer to incur cost you try and send
obscene gifts if you can if not you just
offer to fly out if you can and at the
very least you do a lot of work ahead of
time which I'll get to in a second and
you send the magic message great now
since it's time to send it how many do
we send you send a 100 messages per day
split between as many platforms as
needed 100 there's a rule of 100 it's
consistent across Industries people talk
about it I don't know why but I can't
say that it works and so this will
normally take about 4 hours per day so
set a kitchen timer and send the
messages you'd be amazed at how like if
you just do this it will take you that
long and just rip the Bandit off do it
one day just do it one day and then
you'll realize that you didn't die when
someone doesn't respond and then you can
do it a second day and then a third and
then all of a sudden you'll start
getting responses back I just had a DM
recently from a lady who's like I read
your book I did my first day of the rule
of 100 and she was like I already got 10
responses she's like this is
unbelievable and she spent years
delaying her first
message and I'm both happy for her and
sad for her because imagine the
potential you waste every day you don't
do what you need to do in order to get
where you
want and then you keep repeating this
until you get the
replies bonus points and this is what I
was referencing earlier if you've if you
already follow this influencer and
you've interact with them in some way
you've commented on a story they they
likeed something back then you already
have an in you already have a history
with that person even even tangential
even tiny it still makes you look more
real than
Rakesh now I'll give you also a pro tip
as being a quote super influencer if you
want to call me that share your target
influencer stories so this is what my
DMs look like so this is what my my in
the the outbox looks like or whatever so
lots of stuff weirdo obviously porn blah
blah blah now when I see mentioned you
mentioned you in their story I I create
content and so if someone created
content for me because they mentioned me
then it gives me the opportunity to put
that on my story and if it's valuable
then it provides value to my audience
for no cost to me that's what a
mentioned in a story is on top of the
fact that they're spreading my message
so it's actually like one of the easiest
ways to quote give to a super influencer
is just share what they have and also if
I go into a DM inbox and I see that
they've because you can see how many
times someone has mentioned you or
shared a story of yours and you see 15
shares I think oh shoot you know what
I've incurred a bit of a debt with this
person it's so nice of them to share
this stuff they're making content for me
they're they're spreading people to me I
like them more at the onset day one day
Zero so if you want to get their
attention that's just a little Pro tip
for you and a big reminder because I
want to keep hitting this point is that
you don't need a 100 influencers you
just need one super influencer to take
your company to the next level and
transform your
life so recap on section two on what you
actually say to get them to respond
number one be someone worth responding
to verify yourself two look like a legit
person on your profile three send the
magic message or variations of that and
personalize it personalize it
personalize it offer to incur cost to
meet them that's a little bit more
advanced but it will work send 100
messages per day this takes time but you
only need one and share the super
influencer stories and posts you will
gain more Affinity from them than if you
do nothing at all so now that we have
picked our influencer and we have
optimized our messages and we're sending
them we're going to start getting
replies so here's how you close the deal
here are the steps one over preparation
equals profit two every position has an
advantage three NOS or yeses so let's
dive in so before you speak with them
you want to prepare mockups of what
their thing would look like on your
product or the product that you want to
make for them either way works remember
you can take your Nike shoes and say
we've got this idea for a line and we
want to put it under you or I wi label
drinks and I want to make a drink that's
just for you Logan Paul or I want to
make a tequila just for you the rock or
I want to make a whiskey just for you
Conor McGregor or I want to make
Cosmetics just for you Kylie see where
I'm going with this this is not new but
people aren't seeing it this is why the
opportunity
exists so on top of the mock-ups you
want to show graphs you want to be like
this is you now this is you with me I
say this simply but this is literally
what you want to show someone you want
to show some you actually did a little
bit of math all right and you have some
estimates and projections to go with
that you want to say hey you've got this
many followers
if we post this post x times per week we
assume y reach and we convert 1% of
clicks which is standard based on these
things that I've seen in the past within
12 months we should be able to get to
here does that sound interesting if they
say yes awesome you you're one step
closer to closing the deal if they say
no you find somebody else and you ask
them why is it interesting because you
know what they might give you some of
the best feedback possible and so bottom
line is that you want to show that you
worked a lot on this and this is a key
Point you'll see it as a recurring point
when you're getting with the super
influence I'll tell you why in a second
the main reason you do that is because
they want to work with a partner that's
going to work hard for
them and the best way to prove that
you're going to do it later is to do it
now is to do it first one of my favorite
sayings is the best way to show an
audience that you'll that you'll give
them value after they buy is to give
them value before they buy brilliant I
know but guess what people don't do
they're like I don't want to take I
don't want to be taken advantage of my
time is valuable no it's not and it's
it's also relative you're coming to ask
something from them don't mistake it
like sure you're going to come be like
they're going to benefit too but if
you're going to a super influencer
you're the one who stands to gain far
more than them because they have
themselves and they can make that
partnership with anyone and you want
them to pick
you don't think about the time it takes
you to make this great think about how
much time you're going to save by them
agreeing that you move years of work in
the future rather than the fact that it
takes you a day or two to prepare one
presentation for 15 minutes so that you
crush
it and so for those you like but how do
I structure the presentation this how
you structure the presentation promise
you tell them the good stuff that
they're going to get from the
partnership proof you tell them why they
should believe you past experience or if
you don't have that stats of people like
them doing something comparable and if
you have the product that you think that
they should sell bring it and show it to
them this is called a demo AKA a
demonstration you want to show them that
because if they do have a strong brand
they're going to want want the thing to
be good because they want to make sure
that they're serving Their audience and
so if you've got the bees needs of
products let them taste the
honey three plan tell them what the next
steps look like what's expected of them
and what you're going to do and by the
way make your side look better than
theirs so that they look like they're
getting the best side of the deal and to
be real they should be because they've
already spent all these years leading up
to this so you don't have to spend five
years to build this audience they
already did that and so they're going to
just point which takes little effort but
that's because they're leveraging the
years of work they put in and then
you're going to spend the rest of your
time present forward making out for the
fact that you didn't work the 5 to 10
years to build the brand and that's the
deal and you might still have a smaller
percentage of the overall pie and it's
still worth
it and so finally you've got the proof
you got the promise you got the proof
you got the plan and then you make the
offer so then you make an offer so good
they feel stupid saying no give them a
Michael Jordan offer if they're bigger
than you offer them more more if they're
smaller still offer a lot and I'll give
you a key little Pro tip on this help
them grow if you want to go after a
middle-sized influencer they may want
growth more than they want money and so
then offer them that instead or in
addition so you can give on these
variables it's like okay I can give you
less in the economics but I'm going to
invest all these resources I'm going to
bring Five Guys I'm going to hire for
you to help you 10 extra content so we
both win because real talk if they are
permanently associated with your brand
if they get 10 times bigger guess who
else gets 10 times bigger you
worth
it now I go through those four things
and the thing that most of you guys are
going to struggle with is proof so let's
talk about that so this brings to the
second point of this little mini part
which is getting them to say
yes every position has an advantage and
a disadvantage I really want you to
drill this in all right for example if
you're brand new you sell the benefits
of being brand new so for example I used
to help agency owners with my company
Allen which is a software for for agcy
owners and some of them serve as gym
owners which means they were direct
competition of mine in my other company
gym watch and so they'd say well hey
it's easy for you to get gym owners
you're the 800lb gorilla in the industry
to which I would reply well one I wasn't
always the 800lb gorilla I started at
zero like everyone else but I promised a
different set of benefits I said hey
these companies don't care about you so
if I was in your position I'd be like
Alex doesn't care about you you're just
number to him he he just wants to hit
quota that's what his sales guys are
doing right you're going to get assigned
to some dozen care account rep who just
clocks in every day that they train for
a couple weeks just to get sped up and
they're never going to cater to you but
with
me you're my only brand partner you have
my full attention I don't want 100
Partners I just want one good one I can
go all in on someone I can work day and
night to help and grow and so you have
my contact you have my cell phone you
can come to my house I'll cook you
dinner we'll be partners on this it
would be impossible for them to give you
the same attention as me now if you're
thinking wow that's not a bad point well
then I wonder what the advantage of
being the 800lb gorilla is now if I'm
the 800lb gorilla so once gym launch was
the number one in the industry I would
argue the opposite angle I would say
well we have the best practices across a
lot of accounts and I can feed them
directly to you this kid doesn't have
any other experience I can take the
findings from thousands of accounts and
feed them right to you we have the
infrastructure and skill to just plug
you right into this guy's got to hire
all this I've got specialist across all
these different things that can help you
at a higher level and sure Sarah is only
good at media buying but she's better at
media buying than his
generalist and we can help you scale on
the business side because we already
have we know what we're doing and you'll
know that your audience is getting taken
care of because we have support
infrastructure let's say this thing does
crush well guess what's going to happen
to your little minnow he's going to get
overwhelmed because he's never had this
much attention before we know how to
deal with it we've done it before and so
the question is do you want to trust
your brand as someone who's just getting
into the industry or someone with a
track record do you want to risk what
you work so hard for on someone who
might not even be here in 6 months we've
been here almost a decade and we're
going to keep being here so you're like
wow okay every position has an advantage
and a disadvantage and you sell based on
the position you have in the marketplace
so play to your advantages if you're new
to the game and you're just getting into
and this your first super influencer
partnership then you're going to
emphasize Personal Touch care
flexibility going Allin the owner
mentality of this is us being Partners
we're in this together I'm going to do
anything it takes to get to be
successful now if you're this guy you're
the 800lb gorilla then you're going to
talk about track record the best
practices the infrastructure The
Specialist across functions brand
Association they're going to get from
associating with your brand where they
don't get that with the minnow and once
that happens whichever play you have
they're going to say
yes and if they don't then we go from
our advantages and disadvantages to NOS
or yeses which means we zoom out so
let's talk about that if you don't have
a track record the other reason to over
prepare and make your presentations
exceptional is that you can show them to
other presentations that you make for
other super influencers so if I try to
pitch Kylie on cosmetics and I make this
beautiful deck and I show all these
graphs and all this explanations guess
what I get to use I can take that when I
go to Conor McGregor and I say this is
some of the work that we prepared for
other influencers I'm not saying work we
did for them I'm just saying this is the
type of stuff we do now when you see
that what happens is people are like huh
they're going to see who you're pitching
and they're going to see the work that
you do over and over again they're like
wow this guy sustains a high level of
professionalism and polish despite
business he might not have won it's like
and the subtext is imagine what he' do
if we were actually working together and
that's what you want them to think and
so even if you didn't pitch them this is
the extra Pro tip is that even if you
didn't pitch Kylie or Connor or uh Ryan
Reynolds you can show them alternative
structures that you thought through and
if you show three different versions for
the three different influencers they
might be like okay I saw you prepared me
and that was okay but I really like what
you did with Ryan Reynolds I like that
version can we do something like that
for me and so you give them more options
to bait them in engaging with
you and so all these things help you
look more legitimate and increase the
likelihood that you get one super
influencer and if you get frustrated
don't the gap between no and yes is
where the opportunity to make
life-changing money is and so we went
out over a lot of stuff today and to
bring this home I want to tell you guys
two
stories one from a new business owner
using the super influencer process and
the other from a very large established
business owner because I want to cater
to both people in the audience right now
so I'll start with uh who both use the
strategy for lifechanging wealth so
let's start with a big business owner so
some of you guys have heard of Tony
Robbins in N graos they run a very large
portfolio businesses and they recently
reached out to a super influencer
Matthew mccon and Matthew mccon plugged
in their infrastructure they launched
The Art of Living so it was a product
that Matthew was the front face of and
they did the delivery on the back end
and they branded the product around what
he wanted the art of living and they had
the most people attend ever they had two
plus million people registered for the
that and almost half a million attend
live and a million plus people see it
unlike anything they'd ever had because
they harnessed a single super influencer
with a phenomenal
brand and I point this out to show you a
single partner can bring in
life-changing income and so that's just
an easy big business example all right
those guys had the infrastructure they
reached out I'm sure Tony Robins knowing
all the the presidents and things like
that he was probably one or two phone
calls away from Matthew mccon and he
said yes fine but let's talk about a
small business example because I think
for some of you guys here this may be
the most relevant for you since a
lesters may feel Out Of Reach for some
of you and I want to be clear I don't
think they're Out Of Reach for you I
just think you may feel that way and so
I want to at least meet you where you're
at here's two UK guys Ms and fad and
they added 44,000 per month in recurring
Revenue without ads or a following
neither of these guys has a following
and they weren't even the face and
that's key just like Congo with Logan
Paul no one knows who Congo is no one
who knows who Ms and fad are but when I
show you who they partnered with you
might have heard of them and so here's
what they did they found an influencer
Eddie ABW a former pro bodybuilder from
the UK he only had 50,000 followers at
the time and they reached out just like
I said in the the the presentation
earlier and then he replied doing the
exact thing that I mentioned in the
presentation earlier and then they told
him that he'd be their only partner and
the only client he had just like I said
in the presentation earlier and theyd
spent all of their time growing this
brand which is exactly what they did to
take him from 50k on because that's what
he really cared about and he
agreed and then they asked him if they'd
want to start a paidon on
community and they told him what would
be expected of him and gave him
projections proof promise plan here's
the offer and then they made the proof
promise plan into a presentation for him
notice they focused on branding the
product around him it wasn't the Ms and
Fahad Community it's the abue crew about
people were trying to get in shape get
healthy again and he's older now so he's
a slightly older
demographic which I find actually as a
side note very funny because makes a pot
are 20y old guys all right Eddie Abus is
in his 50s or 60s now and so then they
launched the community
and in the first 30 days two 20-y old
guys with no following and no money got
to 44,000 in monthly recurring Revenue
in the United States at least that's a
top 1% income and I want to be very
clear it's not because like Ms and vad
were able to take five years of work and
compress it into one series of
conversations because they were willing
to give up the upside they were willing
to get rejected by the other hundred
people they reached out to that didn't
say yes so they could get the one that
did and so this worked because Eddie's
audience wanted more high value access
to him so mien vad made that happen very
simple and so they benefited from his
brand and he benefited from their
operations and the work that he wasn't
willing to do so when I talked to them
they were like he uh he just just wants
to make content he doesn't want to do
anything else and so we just said we'll
do everything else we'll bring the
camera we'll do the recording we'll do
the editing we'll even put the stories
up they have the ctas with the links so
that we drive people with the community
and we'll manage the community itself
and we'll send you a cut of the money
and he said
cool and so they both
profited and so the point is if you
actually just follow this process you
can jump forward multiple levels of
income quickly because you only need one
super influencer to change your life
just
one and so for more tactics about this
stuff because we're getting close on
time I have free books and courses on
Outreach using Affiliates also if you
zoom into that little picture of mson
fad you see a little book that they have
in the background the only book they
have referenced there it's book check it
out um and you can watch this stuff on
my site so I actually have the training
for reaching out getting Affiliates more
in-depth stuff more scripts all that
stuff it's absolutely free on my site
acquisition. comom trining it's all free
all right um and if you don't have a
product to recruit a super influencer
with so the first ones if you already
have a product and you and you want to
just go straight to to getting them to
promote it that's what that's for you
and if you don't have a product then you
can start like makes and vad by building
a community for an influencer and the
reason this is kind of like a one fits a
one siiz fits all product for most
influencers is that pretty much every
influencer literally gets followed
because people want access they want
more exposure to them and so all you do
is just have more exposure more content
more access just behind a pay wall so
that the highest fans get what they want
and everybody else still get stuff for
free so it's a win-win all right and so
if you want that school.com games it's
also free to start so if you're like I
don't know what the product you can
start one for free and you can go start
approaching influencers to do it all
right so I hope that I fulfilled my
promise to you from the beginning in the
three-step super influencer process
which is one know how to pick them two
know how to get them to talk to you and
three how to get them to promote your
stuff so you can create life-changing
wealth and hopefully I gave you the
tools to Leap Frog your income if you
actually take action so there's all your
free stuff thank you guys so much enjoy